it's December 2004 and it's almost
Christmas
pottery barn's essential Christmas
holiday trilogy CD set is flying off the
shelves the newly invented Nintendo DS
is on everybody's wish list and George
Hamilton best known for his perpetual
sunkissed glow is starring as Santa
Claus in the ill-conceived made-for-tv
movie a very cool Christmas it's cold
outside
and as insync said in their home for
Christmas holiday album it's the best
time of year for the family the early
2000s have their fair share of iconic
dance sequences but only one truly
captures the holiday spirit
[Music]
yes I choreographed girls dance the
choreography was inspired by a pretty
surprising film remember showgirls you
can get some great moves from strippers
let me tell you when Donna set out to
make the dance though she didn't just
have the plastics in - at least once
that's my personal challenge do you
remember selling magazines and Sally
Foster wrapping paper in middle school
it turns out a lot of us didn't
Sally foster we learned was a real woman
who started selling wrapping paper from
her living room what started as a side
hustle became a 31 million dollar
business and school fundraising program
I just wanted to ask a real person about
this my name is sue Westerberg and I was
on the Parent Teacher Association she's
my middle school best friend's mom and
she headed up our school fundraisers at
one time we used some lye for furniture
for the reception center so help with
that kind of stuff this wish list item
sold 1 million copies in its first 10
days oh yeah it was Sims 2 there are two
things we really remember are loving
about The Sims 1 the cheat codes and to
the Simlish my name is Jackie Perez graz
and I'm an audio director for Sims for
the similars language definitely sounds
like English it's just the words are
nonsensical
we do have a small percentage of words
that do have meaning the most common
phrases that you'll hear our school and
dadgad Vidisha is a big one since 2004
Simlish has evolved nowadays they're
translating Katy Perry in December
perfect and there you have it your
Christmas in 2004 and some of the people
behind it dag dag
[Music]